We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I'm sorry, but if you don't love maps, I don't think we can be friends anymore.
我们得到加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、环境和教育领域最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。我很抱歉，但如果你不热爱地图，我想我们可能做不成朋友了。
I think there are people nowadays who admit that they don't love puppies and kittens and children, but nobody's gonna admit that they don't love maps. kittens and children? But nobody's going to admit that they don't love maps. Maps are awesome, as art, as story, as representation of truth, as representation of lies. Really interesting visual information, it's a little bit like a puzzle, you're solving it, really engages your brain. But it also is an invitation in a way nothing else is. You know, music, somebody else is playing it, but the map,
我想现在有些人会承认他们不爱小狗、小猫和小孩子，但没有人会承认他们不爱地图。小猫和小孩子？但没有人会承认他们不爱地图。地图太棒了，作为艺术、作为故事、作为真理的表征、作为谎言的表征。真正有趣的视觉信息，它有点像一个拼图，你在解开它，非常吸引你的大脑。但它也是一种别的东西无法比拟的邀请。你知道，音乐是别人在演奏，但地图，
it's a score for you to live your own life, to go there and do that, even if you're looking at 12th century Siberia or something and this is the kind of map I really like along with maps of my own neighborhood. And if your only experience with maps is a triple A road atlas, then Rebecca Solnet's new book will blow your mind. This is Rebecca Solnet with Infinite City as San Francisco atlas. It's both a collection of maps and a proposition that any city is infinite because it can be described in infinite ways.
它是你过自己生活总谱，去那里并付诸行动，即使你看到的是12世纪的西伯利亚或类似的东西，这就是我真正喜欢的地图，还有我自家街区的地图。如果你对地图唯一的体验是美国汽车协会（AAA）的公路地图册，那么丽贝卡·索尔尼特的新书会让你大开眼界。这位是丽贝卡·索尔尼特和她的《无限之城：旧金山地图集》。它既是地图的集合，也是一种主张，即任何城市都是无限的，因为它可以有无限种描述方式。
No one map tells you everything about a region. It's 22 maps that want to be beautiful and want to celebrate old-fashioned map making with paper, with drawings, with old cartography, with a sense of wonder and with practical information you can actually go to. We each contain multitudes of maps. If I say to you, there were 99 murders in Ceres' Go in 2008, you know, you'd think it
没有一张地图能告诉你关于一个地区的一切。这是22张地图，它们想要变得美丽，想要歌颂用纸张、绘画、旧制图法、带着惊叹感以及你可以实际前往的实用信息制作的传统地图。我们每个人心中都包含着无数的地图。如果我对你说，2008年旧金山发生了99起谋杀案，你知道，你会觉得
was deplorable for the three seconds before you completely forgot about it. But if I show you the actual map, it makes you think this person died here and that one over there, you see a pattern, you see that most of them are in the east side of town. You know, it becomes particular and specific, it becomes places you could have been, it could have been you, you can go to them, you could bring flowers.
在你完全忘掉它之前的这三秒钟内，这是令人发指的。但如果我向你展示实际的地图，它会让你觉得这个人死在这里，那个人死在那里，你看到了一个规律，你看到其中大多数发生在城镇的东区。你知道，它变得具体而特定，它变成了你曾经去过的地方，那可能就是你，你可以去那些地方，你可以献上鲜花。
And in the San Francisco Infinite City Atlas, these murder sites are represented on the city map as red dots, but alongside them is an array of green dots that represent all of the living, monoray, cypress trees in the city. It's new, ugly, death, and old, beautiful life side by side, sharing a map because, I mean, just because, because you can make a map do anything. My story is my story, but it's a map is also your, because you can make a map do anything. My story is my story, but a map is also your story, because you can literally enter what's shown on the map. You can go there, you can walk it, you can be there.
在《旧金山无限之城地图集》中，这些谋杀地点在城市地图上被表示为红点，但与它们并列的是一排绿点，代表着城里所有活着的、单性的、柏树。崭新的、丑陋的死亡与古老的、美丽的生命并肩而立，共享一张地图，因为，我的意思是，仅仅因为，因为你可以让地图做任何事。我的故事是我的故事，但地图也是你的，因为你可以字面意义上进入地图上显示的内容。你可以去那里，你可以步行去，你可以在那里。
And so maps give you a different sense. They quantify and locate and invite in a way that no other medium does. Would you like any other maps that show other kinds of information? Sure. other medium does. One of the infinite city maps is a treasure map with a panoply of treasured sites in San Francisco. You know the mission Dolores graveyard Monacoirons murals the African Orthodox Church of St. John Coltrane some labyrinths the nesting site of the great blue herons on Sto Lake we have treasure and this is the map to help you find it. But the most curious feature The nesting side of the great blue herons on Sto Lake, we have treasure. And this is the map to help you find it.
因此，地图给你一种不同的感觉。它们以其他任何媒介都没有的方式进行量化、定位和邀请。你还想要其他显示其他种类信息的地图吗？当然。无限之城的地图之一是一张藏宝图，上面有旧金山的一系列珍贵遗址。你知道米慎多洛雷斯墓地、莫纳科龙壁画、圣约翰·柯川非洲东正教教堂、一些迷宫、斯托湖上大蓝鹭的筑巢地，我们有宝藏，而这张地图可以帮助你找到它。但最奇怪的特征是，斯托湖上大蓝鹭的筑巢地，我们有宝藏。而这张地图可以帮助你找到它。
But the most curious feature about this map is that San Francisco isn't depicted as that little thumbnail at the end of the penanceless thumb that it actually is. San Francisco is drawn as an island. On the treasure map, San Francisco not only has the North Coast, East Coast and West and West Coast you all know and love it has a South Coast There's a fictitious blue ribbon of water just north of San Brie, O'Mail There's a lot of ways San Francisco really is in Ireland in terms of its difference from the rest of the country Ecologically geographically and culturally before the bridges You basically came in out of San Francisco by by boats as though it was in Ireland and I just wanted to make that literal and the wonderful way maps always are literal.
但这张地图最奇怪的特征是，旧金山并没有被描绘成那个实际上微不足道的无名指末端的小缩图。旧金山被画成了一座岛屿。在藏宝图上，旧金山不仅有你熟知的北海岸、东海岸和西海岸，它还有一个南海岸。在圣布鲁诺山以北，有一条虚构的蓝色水带。从它与该国其他地区在生态、地理和文化上的差异来看，旧金山在某种程度上确实是一座岛屿。在桥梁建成之前，你基本上是乘船进出旧金山的，就像它是一座岛屿一样，我只是想让它变得具象，就像地图总是具象的那种奇妙方式一样。
So Shizu's, the cartographer Ben Piz's wife Shizu Sikal, obliged me by making San Francisco into an island. Maps are powerful objects. They give direction, they hide secret places, they can support imperialism and oppression. A newly designed map can create a nation state and present a false sense of absolute truth. They change the way we see the world. I joked to some of my friends when I was working on this project that owning racehorses and castles has nothing to commissioning maps when it comes to a sense of power and luxury.
所以，制图师本·皮茨（Ben Pease）的妻子志津（Shizu）——志津·西卡尔（Shizu Sicall）满足了我的要求，把旧金山变成了一座岛屿。地图是强大的物体。它们指明方向，隐藏秘密地点，它们可以支持帝国主义和压迫。一张新设计的地图可以创造一个民族国家，并呈现一种绝对真理的虚假感。它们改变了我们看待世界的方式。我在做这个项目时曾跟一些朋友开玩笑说，在追求权力和奢华感方面，拥有赛马和城堡根本无法与委托制作地图相比。
It's pretty amazing. 99% invisible is produced by me Roman Mars with support from Lunar. It's a project of KLW the American Institute of Architect San Francisco in the Center for Architecture and Design. Find out more at 99%invisible.org There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这太神奇了。《99%隐形》由我罗曼·马尔斯制作，并得到了 Lunar 的支持。它是 KLW、美国建筑师学会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的合作项目。请访问 99%invisible.org 了解更多信息。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。